why am i so bad at basketball take one
step back i feel it i feel it
[Applause]
you see that
what's up y'all it's your girl ari
chambers here with highlight here and
we're live in miami to honor sylvia
fowls and showcase her home court
presented by zell
hey
how are you
doing
welcome to the sunshine station
take me to take me to your court
i got a lot of bruises on my knees from
this court
a lot of bruises on my knees made you
tough made me tough
see i mean
got to get a little messy here we on
your home court
her home court did you have any uh
friends that were rivals that you like
took one-on-one you're like i'm about to
you know come out here and
fall out there was quite a few guys that
came out here thought they was legit you
busted them huh so yeah i'm about to
eat them up all day i love that i love
that but yeah this is where it all
originated from me so all my memories of
this place is like
powerful
all my good mermaids on this court
belongs
here want to know what pride you have in
this neighborhood
this is everything um i tell people all
the time like this this is what made me
it made me who i am and i think i'm so
persistent because i know where i came
from
and to where i'm at now um i'm money
grateful for that when i come back here
it's always love
y'all still look the same can you tell
how proud like you are of her too if you
can't find her on her mom's porch she's
on a basketball
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that is pretty sweet man
that is sweet
[Music]
so i just want to say thank you all for
showing up
uh thank you to the artists back there
who made this thing possible uh without
you guys i wouldn't even be here today
so i just want to say thank you so much
and stress how important it is for like
women figures to be up here actually
showing and leading by example of having
to get it done without miguel and team
pals and miami sons trying to make this
thing happen we wouldn't be here today
so right now i want to thank zell
highlight her for making this thing
possible so coach oh i just want to say
come up on up here
yeah yeah
i think one of the great things that
i've been able to experience you know
doing the girls basketball is that i
feel like we give kids an opportunity a
lot of time kids that maybe not have the
opportunity to go to college and and get
a college education so what the miami
sun has done and what you've been able
to do in my opinion with your
sponsorship it gets it give kids an
opportunity that would not
otherwise have the opportunity because
of the financial support and so with
people like you and people like miguel's
running the organization highlight her
and zell we want to keep the ball
rolling so we're going to send you money
with zell directly to your account all
right thank you thank
you thank you
[Music]
it's definitely inspirational to watch
it shows like how much they care about
us and how we must care about women in
sports
seeing sylvia play she's always been
like a hero to me an inspiration to
always strive to be the best so sill
what does a sense of community mean to
you and how does it feel to be able to
give back with a monetary gift from zell
to your aau team it feels great i feel
honored to be in this situation to be
able to give back to something that came
from the green uh this is who i am and
what i believe in and so to have this
opportunity i'm very blessed and i'm
very fortunate how does your work with
zellen highlighter
contribute to the
to the growing equity and equality of
women in sport well it's definitely a
push and then to have
females forefront of the throne
to let them see visually
that we can do things and so that just
give us that push to make sure the next
generation have that opportunity to do
the same any advice for the kids
in this neighborhood that want to make
it
it's all about just making small strides
everything don't come full throttle
until you make the small steps
uh be committed to what you're doing be
willing to make the sacrifices continue
to work hard and everything will play in
your favor beautiful